evaluate five a squared b squared minus
eight a b plus four a minus seven b
minus a hundred ninety when a is equal
to five and b is equal to negative two
so everywhere we see it if an a here we
should substitute it with a five and
everywhere we see a b here over here we
should substitute it with a negative
with a negative 2. so this is going to
be equal to
it's going to be 5 times
a squared but a is now 5. we're
evaluating when a is equal to 5. so it's
going to be 5 times 5 squared instead of
a b squared we want to put negative 2 in
the place of b so negative
2 squared and then we have
minus 8
times a but instead of an a we want to
put a 5 there
so times 5
times b b is now negative 2.
so times negative 2 plus 4
plus four times a once again a is five
i'm not in i don't wanna do that purple
color a is five in yellow a is five
and then we have minus seven
minus seven times b b is negative two
b is negative two and then finally we
have a minus one hundred and ninety so
you see every time we saw an a
we just substituted the a with 5. so you
see an a here that was right over there
we see an a over there that goes right
over there every time we saw a b
b squared we substituted the b with
negative two solve b we substituted it
with negative two we saw a b
substitute it with negative two and now
we just have to evaluate this expression
using order of operations expo
exponentiation well parentheses always
come first but then exponentiation so
this is going to be 5 times 5 squared so
let's just think about this we're going
to do 5 squared first so 5 squared is 25
negative 2 squared that is positive four
then you have well you don't have to do
any more exponents here so let's just
multiply everything
so we're going to have over here five
times 25 times four 25 times four is a
hundred so it's going to be five times a
hundred so this over here is going to
simplify to 500
and then over here we have
negative 8 times 5 times negative 2.
negative 8 times 5 is negative 40.
negative 40 times negative 2 will be
positive 80. so plus
80. this is going to be positive because
we have a negative times a negative so
we have 40 times 2 which is 80. and then
we have
and then we have this term plus 4 times
5 well that's just going to be 20
and then we have this term negative 7
times negative 2 is positive 14. so this
over here
is positive 14 and then we have to
subtract that 190
we have to subtract 190
and so we have
let's see this over here 500 plus 80 is
580 plus 20s gets us to 600 so this part
is 600 up to that right over there that
is 600 you add 14 you get to 614
and then you have to subtract 190 so we
have 614
minus 190 we could do this in our heads
if we were to subtract 200 it would give
us to 414 but we're subtracting 10 less
so it would be 424.
let's just actually work it out 4 minus
0 is 4.
1 minus 9 can't do that gotta regroup or
borrow we're going to borrow one from
the six and so the one becomes an eleven
eleven minus nine is two five minus one
is four so this is equal to four hundred
and twenty four